bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à bruxelles au coeur du parlement
européen pour ce nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo et dans cette émission nous
irons en allemagne où un petit parti
politique prône la mort de l'euro alors
les allemands sont ils devenus
eurosceptique c'est ce que nous verrons
avec notre invité mais d'abord
l'actualité panneaux solaires chinois
contre vins français
la guerre commerciale est elle déclarée
entre l'union européenne et la chine
c'est la question de la semaine
la chine deuxième partenaire économique
de l'union européenne derrière les
etats-unis en 2012
l'union européenne a enregistré un
déficit commercial de 156 milliards
d'euros avec pékin les produits chinois
inondent l'europe vêtements électronique
jouer services et aussi ses panneaux
solaires produits exportés à très bas
prix par les fabricants chinois
ils menacent l'industrie photovoltaïque
du vieux continent
trois cent mille emplois pourraient
disparaître pour la protéger la
commission européenne propose d'imposer
des droits de douane sur les équipements
venues de chine
bruxelles pointe du doigt les pratiques
déloyales de l'état chinois soupçonnés
de subventionner ces grandes entreprises
mais coup de théâtre le 27 mai dernier
18 pays refusent la taxe anti dumping et
réclame une solution négociée avec pékin
parmi eux les pays bas le royaume uni et
surtout l'allemagne seul état membre a
affiché un excédent commercial avec
pékin
le dossier revient à bruxelles mardi 4
juin la commission européenne hausse le
ton aujourd'hui la commission européenne
a décidé à l'unanimité je vais imposer
des taxes sur les importations de
panneaux solaires chinois pour mettre
fin l'an 2000 sur le marché européen la
mesure entrera en vigueur pour six mois
dès le 6 juin une taxe de 11 8% en
moyenne s'appliquera elle passera à 47,6
% à partir du 6 août
si bruxelles échouent à trouver un
terrain d'entente avec pékin une
décision qui risque de durcir un peu
plus le bras de fer commercial entre les
deux partenaires
pour parler de ce vrai sujet européen
nous sommes avec yannick jadot bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen europe
ecologie les verts membre de la
commission du commerce international
alors la réaction de pékin à ces
annonces de bruxelles n'a pas tardé
puisque la chine a annoncé deux ans a
annoncé le lancement d' enquêtes anti
dumping contre les vins européens
ça y est cette fois la guerre est
déclarée la guerre elle est déjà là la
guerre commerciale
vous savez quand un pays essayent grâce
au dumping social au dumping
environnemental dumping fiscal un
dumping monétaire et on l'a vu sur les
panneaux photovoltaïques
des dizaines de milliards de dollars de
subventions à son industrie
photovoltaïque c'est qu'on est dans une
guerre commerciale et notamment sur des
enjeux comme les énergies nouvelles les
énergies renouvelables qui sont pour
tout le monde d enjeu géostratégique
majeur
donc on est dans cette guerre
commerciale la question aujourd'hui et c
est ce que l'europe se dote des moyens
et des politiques qui lui permettent
d'affronter ses partenaires commerciaux
à la fois dans des logiques de respect
dans des logiques des changes de
partenariat mais aussi de respect et on
a vu malheureusement dans ce cas là
l'europe totalement divisé c'est ce que
dit votre sujet la chine a quand même
réussi ce coup de maître de diviser les
états membres européens est de diviser
les acteurs de la filière photovoltaïque
est ce que c'est la chine qui est trop
forte ou l'europe qui est trop faible
parce que divisés et incapable de
prendre des réactions attend enfin de
réagir à temps que la chine veut y avoir
l'hégémonie sur des secteurs
géostratégique industriels je le
comprends qu'ils le fassent à coups de
milliards c'est logique c'est mais là en
l'espèce c'est l'europe qui est faible
l'europe n'a pas de politique
industrielle c'est un déficit de
construction économique absolument
dramatique aujourd'hui on le voit sur la
sidérurgie
on le voit sur l'automobile et on le
voit maintenant sur l'industrie
photovoltaïque et on a des états qui
essaye de jouer leur intérêt national
leurs intérêts économiques nationales
parfois comme on voit là avec
l'allemagne contre l'intérêt industriel
européen
on est dans finalement vous souvenez
pour le 50e anniversaire du traité de
l'elysée
un des grands sujets ça avait été une
communauté européenne de l'énergie
construite sur le couple franco allemand
est monsieur hollande et madame merkel
s'était promis des partenariats
industriels sur les énergies
renouvelables
on voit que la réponse de madame merkel
c'est moins la communauté européenne de
l'énergie que le couple allemand chinois
autour de l'industrie dans l'immédiat ce
qui a lieu de s'inquiéter pour pour le
vin européen en tout cas dans pour
certains pour l'avenir de la filière
dans certains pays je crois pas je crois
pas parce que vous savez la plupart des
cépages qui sont en chine sur des
cépages français
vous avez vu l'offensive des chinois sur
un certain nombre de grands crus
français
et puis à ma connaissance il n'y a pas
des milliards d'euros de subventions sur
le secteur du vin c'est par secteur ce
qui est un secteur qui se porte bien oui
je crois que c'est un coup de bluff ce à
dire que on sait bien que si on veut
être respecté par les chinois il faut
parfois par l'effort il faut savoir
taper du poing sur la table
c'est ce qu'a fait la commission
européenne dans une situation très
compliquée parce qu' effectivement comme
je disais l'allemagne a passé un deal
avec la chine mais la chine a réussi à
menacer suffisamment un certain nombre
de pays d'europe orientale comme ou la
grèce et de chypre en disant si vous
votez pour les sanctions nous vous
sanctionneront nous mêmes sur les
investissements donc on voit la
faiblesse de l'europe tente en matière
d'investissements qu'en matière de
politique commerciale industrielle en
même temps la commission européenne
était dans son rôle a là au moins
annoncer des mesures ces mesures pour
vous elles sont elles sont pas
suffisantes elle arrive trop tard les
taxes les fameuses taxes sont tardives
ça fait un an que les états unis ont
imposé des droits de douane jusqu'à 250
%
elles sont provisoires ça c'est la
logique du système européen
elles sont insuffisantes mais encore une
fois quand la commission fait face à une
majorité du conseil qui est plutôt
opposés à ces menaces je trouve que la
commission a été relativement courageuse
mais ce qu'a donné neuf mois d' enquête
de la part de la commission européenne
c'est que les panneaux chinois sont
vendus sur les marchés mondiaux et donc
pénètre le marché européen à la moitié
de leur coût de revient comment voulez
vous qu'une seule entreprise européenne
résistent à ça vous voyez les
entreprises européennes tombées les unes
derrière les autres
alors que ce sont des entreprises
innovantes performantes compétitive qui
créent des emplois qui créent des
réseaux sur nos territoires donc on
l'europe ne peut pas lâcher cette
industrie là où à imaginer que l'europe
ne soit qu'une économie de services on a
vu que ça marchera pas dans les taxes
sur les panneaux solaires chinois a
annoncé par la commission européenne
vont s'appliquer pendant une durée de
six mois en deux temps avec un taux
d'abord de 18% et ensuite de 47% ça
laisse quand même le temps pour à
l'europe pour négocier ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya une place pour la
négociation avec les chinois
vu le contexte et les divisions des
européens les le principe des mesures
anti-dumping c'est de remettre de la
concurrence loyale quand elle met plus
loyal quand elle devient déloyale
donc c'est pas normalement une mesure
définitive c'est ça doit entraîner
générer une négociation pour que les
entreprises chinoises ne bénéficie plus
et n'interviennent plus avec ce dumping
là que certains évoluent et évalue à 30
milliards de dollars c'est considérable
sur ce type d'industrie et ou avec les
autorités chinoises pour que ça s'arrête
à partir du moment où ça s'arrête
il n'y a aucun problème moi mon mon
sujet c'est pas de fermer le marché
européen au panneau chinois c'est de
faire en sorte que la concurrence soit
loyale parce que je sais que les
européens ont d'incroyables atouts à
jouer sur le photovoltaïque et c'est
plein d'entreprises qui sont en train de
tomber parce que l'europe ne
réagissaient pas et bien merci beaucoup
et yannick jadot d'avoir été notre
invité pour commenter cette actualité
chargée
l'actualité c'est aussi les événements
aux portes de l'europe en turquie où les
affrontements se poursuivent entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre la
turquie qui s'embrase nous en parlons
dans un instant avec une journaliste
turque mais d'abord ces images qui ont
fait le tour des télés européennes
la protestation touche désormais les
quatre plus grandes villes de turquie
sans aucun signe d'essoufflement ce sont
les manifestations les plus violentes
que le gouvernement erdogan affronte
depuis qu'il est au pouvoir
l'étincelle qui a mis le feu aux poudres
c'est la décision du gouvernement de
construire un centre commercial dans un
parc d'istanbul fond dedans mais au fond
cela traduit le mal être des défenseurs
de la laïcité devant l'islamisation
croissante du pays et l'autoritarisme du
premier ministre le premier ministre est
au pouvoir depuis onze ans et il n'aime
guère la critique
même la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme lui a demandé de faire des
efforts ils se défendent islamiser la
société mais différentes mesures mettre
de l'eau au moulin des opposants comme
celles voulant interdire aux amoureux de
s'embrasser dans le métro ou encore le
rouge à lèvres trop prononcé banni des
visages des hôtesses de l'air projet
tellement décriée qu'ils ont été
abandonnés des manifestants qui nettoie
eux mêmes la place où ils se rassemblent
des scènes déjà vues ailleurs comme en
egypte l'an dernier pour autant il n'est
pas garanti que la place taksim devienne
la future place tahrir de la turquie
d'abord parce qu'on voit sur ces images
la foule rassemblée aujourd'hui est
beaucoup moins importante qu'hier mais
aussi parce que seules certaines
organisations d'extrême gauche comme
celle ci affiche la volonté de se
rassembler ici quotidiennement
la diaspora turque soutient les
manifestants en turquie en europe des
familles suivent avec inquiétude le
déroulement des manifestations
l'attachement aux valeurs d'atatürk le
père de la turquie moderne et très
important et c'est tout un symbole pour
ces turcs une de la diaspora que
d'entonner leur hymne national
que se passe-t-il exactement en turquie
pour tenter de le comprendre nous sommes
avec une journaliste turque bonjour
bonjour gülsüm alan vous êtes
correspondante ici à bruxelles pour
plusieurs médias européens
on voit une foule très hétéroclite avec
des revendications diverses
qu'est ce qu'elle demande cette foule de
la place de la place taksim pardon
quelles sont les vraies raisons de la
colère alors il faut savoir que les
événements qui ont éclaté à la place
taksim donc les manifestations il ya
plusieurs raisons il ya une seule raison
les gens qui manifestent sont pour la
majorité des cas ils sont dérangés par
le comportement par la façon de parler
du premier ministre l'egypte albert
douane par la façon d'agir de l'éjecter
aldo raine puisqu'il y a une il dit
croissance économique à tout prix c'est
à dire des projets d'urbanisation
démesurée à istanbul
ce qui dérange fortement les
istanbuliote est aussi le reste de la
turquie puisque c'est un patrimoine
historique à protéger pourvu c'est pas
un rejet de l'islamisation croissante de
la société c'était pas ça la vraie
raison je pense qu'on peut simplifier
on peut pas dire que c'est une
opposition entre islam et laïcité vu que
parmi les manifestants on retrouve aussi
bien des environnementaux des personnes
qui qui sont contre le gouvernement des
opposants mais aussi des conservateurs
des personnes qui ont voté pour la ké pé
comme on a pu le voir les premiers jours
des manifestations il y avait des femmes
voilées
il y avait aussi des femmes non voilées
et il ya tout tout tout personne qui est
contre le comportement d'erdogan se
retrouvent dans la rue aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on peut parler de printemps
turcs ou c'est pas du tout ça ce n'est
pas comparable du tout à ce qui s'est
passé sur la place tahrir cette fois en
egypte ça vous fait aussi cette
comparaison
alors c'est vrai que les images nous
rappellent un peu les ailes la place
tahrir le printemps arabe mais on peut
absolument pas comparer le printemps
arabe avec le printemps on peut pas dire
qu'il ya un printemps tueur puisqu'il ya
des élections démocratiques qui ont lieu
en turquie depuis 1950 et on peut pas
comparer la turquie est un pays arabe où
il ya eu ou qui a été dirigée depuis 40
ou 50 ans par un régime dictatorial et
les et des élections en turquie sont
reconnus en tant que démocratique par le
conseil de l'europe donc il faut voir
cela et donc c'est un gouvernement qui a
été élu politiquement et électoralement
de manière légitime et pour vous
l'héritage
laïque de la turquie moderne l'héritage
d'atatürk n'est pas menacée l'héritage
laïque donc il faut il faut que air doan
donc le premier ministre change sa
manière de se comporter de s'exprimer
envers la population et qu'il y ait plus
de dialogue avec la population pour pour
consommer 30 finalement c'est tout à
fait ça qu'on lui reproche donc c'est un
peu plus de dialogues peut-être faire
des référendums pour savoir qu'est ce
qu'on construit où et comment faire pour
changer la ville le visage la silhouette
d'istanbul à quoi elle va ensemble et et
où va la turquie donc c'est aussi un
dialogue c'est vraiment le dialogue
d'ailleurs bülent arinç le vice premier
ministre a cherché l'apaisement en
s'excusant auprès de la population pour
les manifestants blessés est vraiment
lâché la turquie cherche l'apaisement
actuellement puisque ces événements ont
fait des morts déjà où va la turquie
justement des négociations d'adhésion
sont toujours en cours depuis plusieurs
années avec l'union européenne est ce
que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ça peut
remettre en cause ces discussions
catherine ashton l'a bien précisé que
les négociations ne seront pas remises
en cause
à cause des événements qui ont eu lieu
en turquie ces derniers temps il faut
savoir que les négociations avec l'union
européenne ont commencé en 2005 tout
comme avec la croatie en même temps que
la croatie la croatie va bientôt entrer
dans l'union européenne mais la turquie
est toujours à la traîne piétine pour
plusieurs raisons l'union européenne a
aussi une part de responsabilité là
dedans puisque plusieurs chapitres ont
été débloqués par notamment la france et
chypre donc notamment sur la question
des droits de l'homme qui est notamment
sur la question des droits de l'homme et
compte bendit l'a dit
le jour précédent a dit que la turquie
est que l'union européenne devrait ce
retour devrait accorder plus d'attention
et l'union européenne et peut-être
ouvrir les chapitres sur les droits de
l'homme la justice ce qui est un point
quand même à soulever et on reparlera
très prochainement sans doute de la
situation en turquie merci beaucoup
bulls une alarme d'avoir été avec nous
l'émission se poursuit dans un instant
françois beaudonnet et son invité le
député allemand andreas soit pour parler
de la situation politique en allemagne
et notamment de l'arrivée d'un nouveau
parti alternative pour l'allemagne
regardez d'abord ce reportage à hambourg
signée chloé baïse je voudrais signé
s'il vous plaît dans ce quartier
populaire de hambourg le docteur corner
fait campagne pour le nouveau parti
eurosceptique alternative pour
l'allemagne l'accueil des passants est
plutôt réceptifs à ce propos je suis
contre l'euro et j'aimerais revenir au
deutsche mark
depuis que nous avons l'euro tout est
vraiment devenu plus cher ben ali
parmi les signataires beaucoup sont
insatisfaits du gouvernement
même en gueule à merkel n'est plus
capable de tenir l'allemagne on a encore
plus d'étrangers venus de pologne et de
république tchèque et donc plus de
chômage et de misère alors dans la ville
fondatrice du parti les candidats sont
sur le pied de guerre avant les
prochaines élections fédérales en
septembre
on a des signatures pour en bourse entre
le nord altona encore le centre nous
avons besoin de 1600 signatures pour la
liste régionale et chaque candidat doit
réunir 250 signatures comme nous sommes
six candidats en cours
ça fait en gros trois mille signatures
des signatures qu'ils sont tout près
d'obtenir car même ici en allemagne le
pays européen le moins touché par le
chômage et la crise lors au scepticisme
gagne du terrain
alternative pour l'allemagne entend
proposer une autre politique européenne
plus drastiques que celles d'angela
merkel nous sommes vraiment pro européen
mais nous sentons que l'europe souffre
de deux choses tout d'abord l'euro qui
est un problème pour l'europe parce que
cela ne marche pas et puis deuxièmement
la commission européenne de bruxelles
qui n'est pas démocratique
date à l'origine du parti une pétition
d'une centaine de professeurs d'économie
critiquant la ligne laxiste de bruxelles
un programme protectionnistes et libéral
pour une formation qui vise d'abord
l'élite intellectuelle et les classes
professionnelles supérieures pour ces
universitaires une chose est sûre
l'allemagne paye trop pour le reste de
l'europe que nous voulons c'est re
concevoir l'euro de telle sorte et bien
que les seuls pays assez compétitifs
puisse rentrer dans le rang et cela veut
dire que certains pays méditerranéens et
bien sortir les pays en crise de l'union
européenne l'idée fait son chemin chez
les allemands selon un récent sondage
ils sont plus de la moitié contre le
maintien de la grèce dans l'euro
20 % d'entre eux envisagent aussi un
retour au deutsche mark
pour entrer au parlement il faudra qu
alternative pour l'allemagne tiennent 5%
des votes
la plupart des sondages le placent
plutôt autour des 3%
peu probable donc qu'il provoque un
bouleversement dans l'opinion
je ne pense pas qu alternative für
deutschland s'adresse à beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de personnes qui se
posent la question d'aller voter
pourrait se sentir concernés par les
propositions du parti alternative für
deutschland peut être un danger c'est
pour la td ou et le spd les partis
libéraux fdp
rendez vous avec des militants certains
ont quitté les rangs de la cdu le parti
majoritaire d'angela merkel pour
rejoindre alternatif für deutschland
et si les nouveaux membres sont unanimes
sur le programme économique
la discussion s'envenime lorsqu'il
aborde les thèmes sociaux
nous sommes de culture chrétienne et
occidentale nous ne devons pas l'oublier
français italiens espagnols
nous sommes des chrétiens d'occident peu
importe si on est catholique ou
évangélistes ou je ne sais quoi c'est
notre culture notre tradition et on se
laisse de plus en plus envahir
alternatif pour l'allemagne va s'y
encore entre le conservatisme bon temps
et le populisme
le parti devrait définir sa ligne pour
de bon lors de son premier congrès
national au mois de juin un reportage
signé chloé baïse alors nous sommes sur
ce plateau avec andreas schwab bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen vous
êtes allemand vous êtes du groupe ppe
quand on voit ce reportage là on
s'interroge on y tient est ce que
l'allemagne ne serait pas en train de
tomber du côté des eurosceptiques en
europe
je ne pense pas le reportage a
clairement indiqué qu'il y a un certain
mécontentement dans la population
qui a probablement toujours été présent
vous vous rappelez des mouvements
politiques au moment de l'introduction
de l'euro qui sont échouées avec moins
d'un pour cent dans les élections en
allemagne et donc je pense que si les
partis qui défendent l'euro se mettent à
expliquer mieux ce qu'ils ont fait ce
qu'ils veulent faire
c'est une bataille qu'on peut gagner on
a quand même l'impression que ce que
disent les allemands certains allemands
en tout cas dire on paye trop pour les
autres on paye trop pour les grecs on
paye trop pour les portugais les
espagnols etc
c'est quand même quelque chose qui a un
écho non en allemagne
oui mais moi je viens de bade wurtemberg
c'est le sud-ouest de l'allemagne et
légendes dans ma région dans ma
circonscription se plaignent depuis des
cinquantaine d'années qu'on paye trop
pour les autres allemands on était on a
été toujours un pays un land qui paient
pour les autres länder
donc ce système de transfert est présent
en allemagne et donc je connais cette ce
mécontentement et c'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau c'est vrai que la
communication de la politique de l'euro
n'a pas été parfaite mais c'est aussi un
sujet très complexe
vous dites communication mais c'est un
fait enfin je veux dire l'allemagne est
le premier contributeur à la fois sur le
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
c'est elle qui paye le plus pour aider
les pays en difficulté donc au delà du
la communication qui est peut-être pas
excellente
c'est quand même une réalité ça les
citoyens j'imagine le savent mais c'est
aussi un fait positif que l'allemagne a
retrouvé cette force d'être en mesure de
contribuer au bien-être en europe de
contribuer à des politiques de réforme
en europe entière il ya dix ans on avait
eu du mal à s'imaginer toutes ces
politiques qui sont maintenant mis en
place tous ses réformes
donc je pense on a eu beaucoup de succès
jusqu'à maintenant
malheureusement ce n'est pas encore
sensible les gens ont l'impression
qu'ils ont mis qui sont mis dans des
problèmes au lieu d'être de penser que
c'est quelque chose de les réformes sont
quelque chose de positif
mais je crois fortement que au long
terme il va s'avérer que c'était des
réformes nécessaires et positives pour
les populations alors en compte ce
reportage
les balises rencontré un journaliste
allemand il a une remarque à vous faire
et ensuite j'aurai savoir ce que vous en
pensez on écoute à la dignité des
statistiques qui laissent à penser que
le phénomène des petits partis peut
potentiellement prendre des voix aux
grandes formations
par exemple il joue sur le sentiment
anti européen
les allemands sont désorientés ils ne
savent pas exactement combien leur coûte
l'europe et ses salles argument
principal d'alternative sur d'autres
champs alors il ya des élections
importantes évidemment au mois de
septembre importante pour l'allemagne et
pour madame merkel est ce que vous
pensez que ce qui est dit là est vrai
est ce que bon évidemment ce parti ne
sera pas majoritaires mais ce que
l'addition des petits partis comme ça ça
peut mettre des grands partis comme
celui de madame merkel en difficulté
moi je n'y crois pas il est vrai que on
n'a pas la volonté politique en
allemagne
d'ailleurs au nom plus en france de dire
la vérité
l'europe va baisser de population en
l'an 2000 sans l'europe contrat encore
pour 5 portes pour cent de la population
mondiale avec 5% de la population
mondiale
vous n'avez justement rien à dire et
donc peu importe où vous habitez à paris
ou à berlin
donc la perspective devant laquelle nous
nous trouvons c'est une perspective à
long terme où l'europe va baisser en
poids politique en poids économique
donc pour trouver des solutions à cela
il faut qu'on travaille ensemble et peu
importe comment on explique qu'il faut
que la population comprenne que
l'européenne est une nécessité pour nous
défendre à nous et je pense on n'a pas
la force politique de le dire de cette
clarté et ça manque
est ce que l'europe sera au coeur de la
campagne électorale en allemagne le
peut-être pas l'europe mais l'euro et je
trouve ça c'est le premier point une
marque d'identification des européens
dans tous les pays européenne on discute
aujourd'hui sur la solution de la crise
de l'euro la crise des dettes en euros
et ça c'est quelque chose qui se discute
n'importe où en europe et ça montre que
l'europe est en train de devenir plus
européen qu'on est là qu'on ne l'avait
pas pensé avant
lors de la dernière campagne électorale
en france pour l'élection présidentielle
l'europe était assez absente finalement
parce que si on sait que quand on parle
de l'europe on va on ne gagne pas de
voix au contraire on a même plutôt
tendance à en perdre
est-ce que ça va être quand même un peu
la même chose ou est ce que madame
merkel dont auquel part que sa
partenaire son parti est ce que elle va
mettre ça en avant les bienfaits de
l'euro est ce que c'est quelque chose
est ce que c'est un discours qui veulent
qu'elle va tenir je pense qu'elle est
convaincue qu'il ya des effets positifs
de l'euro pour l'allemagne d'effet
économique est aussi financier positif
pour l'allemagne mais il est très
difficile d'expliquer ça aux gens car
aux états unis on dit entre le tic cela
ôte toute politique et locales et donc
les les domaines politiques qui sont
assez loin temps sont très difficiles à
expliquer site c'est un fait et
malheureusement je crains qu'on va aussi
se heurter à ce fait est dans la
campagne électorale en allemagne
dernière question vous êtes allez vous
êtes surtout député européen est ce que
vous allez sentiment que ce qui se passe
en allemagne avec alternatif für
deutschland est révélateur de ce qui se
passe dans d'autres pays européens avec
la montée des populismes
absolument il y à un mouvement dans tous
les pays de l'europe d'un certain nombre
de personnes de gauche extrême gauche de
droite d'extrême droite et donc je pense
que c'est rien de vraiment c'est aucune
chose qui doit nous faire peur ça vous
inquiète pas pour les prochaines
européennes ça m'inquiète pas si on
n'arrive à expliquer pourquoi nous
faisons tout ça merci andres pape
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
c'est la fin d'europe hebdo on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine et d'ici
là bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
à